hey
how you doing bro
thank you also going through man
pleasure to meet you absolutely what's
up welcome back to my channel thank you
so much for watching i want to introduce
you
to a great guy called carl who's
accumulated a large
property portfolio of rent to rents he's
grossing 92
000 pounds a year started from
absolutely nothing
and just studied my youtube videos and
has now become really successful
so i hope you enjoy the interview don't
forget to hit the like button
also subscribe to the channel for more
videos like this but right now
hey cole great to have you in my home
thank you very much pleasure to be here
you felt a little bit surreal when you
first walked in because we've not met
before in person no i haven't no
no no it was very strange the drive up
here was very um yeah surreal
um because obviously i've seen you on
youtube quite a lot
you've been watching me for years bro
yes yeah yeah um
yeah years on tv youtube um read your
books
um so yeah very surreal so what was the
moment
when you first decided you wanted to be
a property investor
so it came out of the blue
i was looking for something i didn't
know what
um i was i've been a retail manager for
20 odd years
i've tried different things i've tried
different businesses they've all failed
i was used to failing that wasn't a
problem so diving in was never a problem
i was used to failing um
and it was about five years ago five six
years ago
quite a tough time i've been through a
divorce recently had no money
i was working all the hours under the
sun um it was a crazy time
and i was still i was that guy that you
know googles
how to make more money passive income um
side hustles all that i was sat there
googling it every night trying to
look for that light bulb moment you know
what's there's got to be something more
there's got to be another way
um stock markets obviously were
a big suggestion every time but that
just wasn't me um
knew nothing about them at the time um
so yeah
it was just quite out of the blue really
just one night i was actually sat
watching tv
um and the program came on and i just
left it on
and it was called the week the landlords
moved in yeah another show
and you were on it the bbc i believe so
yeah yeah if i remember right
um and it was interesting i got into it
i thought this was great this this is
and then obviously introduced the
landlords
and that was the first time i ever
considered property as a business
i'd never ever considered it i've never
made the connection before
yeah property to me landlords to me was
a guy who's had his grandma's house left
to him and now he rents it out
that was a landlord it wasn't a business
never considered it
so obviously that show opened my eyes
quite a lot there were you guys on there
with all these houses
and rolling around in these nice cars
and
there was one i remember watching you on
it and there was one line on there
this line changed my life it was this
moment i sat up in my chair
and it's when you said i spend about
five minutes
a month working on my property business
yeah
and i just literally went i have to do
this i don't know how
but this is what i've been looking for
the penny drops light bulb went on
and that was it my mood instantly
changed i knew exactly
what i wanted to thought this is it this
is this is a business this is what i've
been looking for this is what i've been
trying to find on google this is what
i've been thinking about the last five
ten years yeah this is what's going to
change my life so since then
you took a serious binge
into my youtube channel a deep dive
yeah and you've watched pretty much
every video on there youtube um
social media followed everything um
just really sort of delved into this new
world that i discovered yeah and not a
lot of
i mean obviously quite a lot of
landlords i'm not sure you know
very few were putting content out like
you were in fact i don't think anybody
was
um and just content content content
youtube and i thought
this this is exactly what i've been
looking for this is amazing
um and a lot of people as well you know
a lot of people
will watch a video and be inspired but
then they don't actually take any action
when was it when you started actually
taking action because that was
five and a half years ago when did you
go on your first property viewing call
your first age and put in your first
offer
so the first thing i ever did
um was i went to see probably about
three years ago
i went to see an accountant who had
found
local to me who seemed to specialise in
property and things i thought i just
need more advice i need to know what i'm
doing on
what i'm up against i need to go on a
fact-finding mission now
and see you know get down to the
nitty-gritty and see what i can find out
i went seen his accountant he basically
said yes it can be done
go do more research he wasn't much help
to be honest i thought back to square
one
so more youtube videos more books more
research um still have no money at this
point i was still working loads and
all the money was coming in and then
going out um
and then it started getting more and
more serious in my mind i discovered
a couple of years ago maybe um
when i was watching i think one of your
interviews
this thing called rent to rent yeah
because i had no money to buy a house
so i thought well how am i going to do
this why were you so skinny when you've
been working as like a manager and
things
um divorce um kids to pay for
bills debts cars to pay loans to pay off
i was
on my own at that point as well so
everything that
was sort of shared was now all mine
all the dips were mine um and retail
management
isn't that well paired yeah people maybe
think it is
you work a lot of hours um and you get
an average wage
um so it was just what came in went out
what what did your friends family think
of the idea of you
this guy who's got no money but has been
watching
a guru on youtube i mean did your
friends and family have anything to say
um i didn't tell
a lot of them i didn't talk about it
that much why not i felt like my little
dirty secret because i knew i wanted to
do it but i just didn't know how
and the few people i did tell there was
a couple of laughs and like
okay you know it was just the next thing
because i'd started and failed a few
businesses what
why did you fail before what happened i
don't know just i think my heart wasn't
in it
um like i'd started a hot tub for hire
business
and that spiked and fell and crashed and
that was it
too many people doing it um
i tried i'd looked into everything i
tried to buy a candle shop
believe it or not because i knew
somebody who worked there and i knew
what kind of money it turned out i knew
the profit margins
so i had to get some money to buy this
shop yeah eventually i found a guy an
investor who was willing to go in with
me
yes we've got the money the shop was for
sale um
contacted the guy who won the shop and
he just accepted an offer three days
before that
so that fell flat but the idea of buying
that shop was to take the money from the
shop and put it into property
was the idea so nothing had quite seemed
to just take off nothing gelled with me
no it was just a way of making money
nothing really
like i say my heart wasn't in anything
because i knew it was just a way to make
money
no not something i really wanted to do
so what was different about property
what was it that really gave you that
spark
it was just exciting it's it's limitless
it's
you can go as far as you want with it
and i'd worked hard all my life i'd done
107 hours in a week once at work i'd
done 24 hour shifts
crazy i worked and worked and worked and
worked
and i didn't have any more money for it
yeah
so the line that you said
on the show i spent five minutes on my
property business
a month i thought i need to do this
yeah i need to do this because i can do
this around all the commitments i can do
it
you know in my spare time i can i can
scale it as much as i want um but again
didn't know how
so then when i discovered rent to rent
another big light bulb
that's how that's how i'm gonna do it so
how would you describe
what rent to rent is
rent to rent is
[Applause]
well basically i pay the long load
i set feet every month to look after his
property
he basically gives me free run to do as
much as i want with his property
i'll refurb it if it needs it
um i'll tenant it i'll manage the
tenants and i'll take what's left after
he's got his fee
sure so he's got an easy life he's got
an easy life
it's hassle-free trouble-free for him he
doesn't have to think about this
property
he gets a guaranteed lump sum every
month from me
and i keep the rest and presumably
you're not gonna rent it to one family
no you're gonna split it up so hmos yes
so
yeah uh multi-let's hmos young
professionals
that's the target and where are you
based
so i'm based in west yorkshire and i
have one in west yorkshire i have one in
south yorkshire and i have one in
greater manchester so you've got three
rental rents
and what's the sort of figures on them
give me an idea of how much you're
making on those
um so all three combined is bringing in
seven and a half to eight grand a month
is that profit
no that's gross gross profit maybe half
that
so you're making about half that which
is sort of talking about three or four
grand
three and a half grand three and a half
grand a month yeah which is coming in
it's recurring how much do you work for
that now
um i choose to work about an hour a week
on it
so you've been to almost the five
minutes a month not quite but
not quite there but i probably could if
i chose to that's great
i just like to keep on top of the
adverts fresh photos yeah absolutely
so do you manage it yourself or just you
manage it yourself yeah
myself for my partner becky she's been a
big driving force i met becky um two
three years ago
and she was a massive driving force
behind it as well so we sort of get
together she wanted to do property her
life as well
yeah but again never really got into it
um
now some people might be watching this
thinking okay you're making three and a
half grand a month
that's not really that impressive but
the thing is
if you're just spending about an hour a
week on it it's
it's not about the fact that you're
making loads of money no
it's about the i mean when you walked
into this uh to this house the first
thing you said to me she said you've
changed my life
yeah and although it's not a crazy
amount of money it is a life-changing
amount of money it is because it
replaced my income
which was the main thing that was the
main thing i couldn't seem to get
anything going because i was working all
the time
yeah all the time i was at work all the
time and i had nothing to show for it
um so now i can do what i want with the
rest of my time and i've still got his
money coming in
yeah and i've done that i've just
completed a diploma in clinical
hypnotherapy so i'm now hypnotherapist
just because you wanted to
because i wanted to yeah and i'll do
something else after that
just because i can so for you it's about
financial freedom yes
so so that's that's interesting to know
talk to me a little bit about life
before and after then i mean you've
mentioned the diploma
yeah totally different totally different
um like i said my life before was work
and um any days off would be
kids and that was it i needed working
kids and working kids there was nothing
else
and then i'd lay in bed googling how to
make more money in my spare time
and that was it it was miserable um it
was just
filled having the kids was fantastic
that wasn't miserable that was fantastic
but the work was miserable and the work
took over a lot of it yeah an awful lot
of it
um and i felt as i couldn't really
provide
for my kids properly i couldn't provide
for their future
there was no savings there was nothing
um and it just didn't feel right
yeah i just knew something had to change
something had to change
and then when it did and when the
property thing started um i
met becky we got our heads together we
both said yes we want to do it
and she sort of pushed me you know go
you know you want to do it let's do it
so we did and we we looked into it more
and more and then when we decided to do
it
we covered it so it was like oh what do
we do now
because we knew we wanted to rent to
rent we knew it was hmo
social living covered hit nobody wants
to be nearing anybody else so
he's right right you do but
we had a state we had i think we had a
bit of money at that point
um to get started um
so june just after the first lockdown
really the first lockdown was sort of
still in place
we were both on furlough from work and
we said let's go for it june last year
we made a limited company in july we got
the first house
august we got the second and life just
changed
so it was when so furlough kind of gave
you the time then
interesting yeah so you had a little a
little bit of money where did that
little bit of money come from was that
the savings it was actually
a bit of savings but a bit of
inheritance as well sadly becky lost her
grandma
a bit before that and she left us a bit
of money so and becky wanted to do
property as much as i did
um and i had sort of shown you your
videos and
books and i had all these books on the
bookshelf and she was like
let's do it and a lot of people have had
a few grand
a lot of people would put that into a
getting a new car or
they might put it into a holiday or even
putting it on a down payment on a house
for themselves yeah but you put it into
a
business there was no thought of doing
anything else with it apart from
the property business yeah yeah there
was no temptation to do anything else
so are you still working in your normal
job now you quit yeah
financially free how does it feel
amazing to have quit
absolutely amazing i feel like i'm in
charge of my own life
yeah i feel like i can make my own
decisions i feel like
i can do a diploma if i want to do a
diploma yeah i can do all of them
so with the rental events itself then
talk to me a little bit about the deals
how you got them how you found them so
i wanted to get going i wanted to speed
it up
so i cheated a little bit and i had a
deal source
so we just paid the deal saucer
researched and researched found a good
one
um i had a deal saucer i got myself a
little bit of training but
when i got the training i then realized
i knew 95 of it anyway because i've
spent all these years
watching and reading and following and
what training did you do
um it was some online training because i
was i'd seriously considered the crash
course so many times yeah and for one
reason or another work
or family or recovered or something got
in the way
and i could never get there um
so i paired a guy called paul he did
some online training he sent me the
training i watched it
and i just ran with it it was three
videos
so talk to me about that that how you
how you so did you did you pay deals
offer on all three or
deal saucer for all three yeah okay cool
yeah so talk to me did you
in the tenants did you find those yes so
talk to me about then
how you not only found the deal but also
found the tenants yeah filled it the
whole process
how how did you do it so um
would get the deal off the deal saucy do
the contracts and things um
and would go see the house now at that
point as well i was learning how to
stack deals myself um so you can
surround yourself with brilliant people
but you've got to know what's going on
yeah you've got to be able to double
check it do your own due diligence as
you talk about all the time
and you've got to be able to do that so
i did but the deal stacked the deals
were great
the first one was in sheffield um which
is where i got my
rent to rent on the financial freedom
challenge there you go yeah it was yeah
exactly
for some reason i don't know why i
always wanted to sheffield at some point
i wanted to be in sheffield yeah the
first one came along and it was
sheffield
i thought this is another sign thank you
um so a five bed
um he negotiated with the landlord
foreign i met the landlord
the landlord wanted to meet myself and
my partner becky before
anything because he'd never done this
before right he had this one he was
wanting to retire um he had this house
it was a next student that obviously
coverage students had gone home
they didn't know when they were coming
back so student let's we're all sat
empty
um and it just been refurbed
a fire bed brand new new carpets
newly painted new kitchen so you didn't
have to do much to it then
very little we just basically dressed it
feature wall paint
dressed it um
how much were you paying the landlord on
that first deal on that first deal would
pay the landlord eight to five a month
why do you think the landlord wouldn't
just rent it out himself as a hmr
it was too much work not too hard he
didn't want to have the hassle of it
anymore
they've done student less if i think he
found student let's quite easy because
they're pretty much in for the year when
they're in it's a once a year tenant
fine really on a student
yeah um students were no longer an
option
because i've covered so the idea of
filling it with
working people i think just he was too
daunted by it i would say
he just didn't know how to do it didn't
really know didn't
really want to take the risk um
and we came along offered him guaranteed
rent totally hands off
sit at home and just get his money every
month was it scary taking that first
deal
yes how did you feel um
we got it we spent some money decorating
it and putting furniture in and things
like that
um it was exciting signing the deal and
then when the house was ready
and we put the adverts out that was a
scary bit
because for two days there was nothing
ooh no calls
no replies we didn't really know what we
were doing we thought we did
but we had nothing to test it against so
obviously all of a spare room and
everywhere else and
um so that was a bit scary so what
happened
then the phone started ringing so the
first two days it was just two days god
just playing with you what have we done
right
and you were nervous because you've got
to play the landlord the hm5
you've got to pay him regardless yeah so
that's the risk
yeah and the thing is if there was no
risk then there would also be you can't
have no risk and nobody
you can have no reward that's the thing
i think all the other things i tried and
failed at
phil you didn't scare me because i was
sort of used to it
um i didn't want it but it wasn't new to
me
but i didn't expect to fail i believed
it would work and i believed it for five
six years
yeah it took you a long time to bite the
bullet and actually go for it it did
yeah it did so
how long did it take you to fully rent
out that entire house that first house
three weeks
why not bad yeah so you're paying a lot
of 85 and how much rent did you
whether you now getting for it so that
house profit because we pay the bills as
well as you do generally with these
deals
um so i generally profit around 900 a
month
from that very nice yeah 900 a month
yeah from a five bed
five bed and are they on sweets only one
on sweet
okay interesting yeah so then once
you've done that you just did the same
thing again
rinse and repeat rinse and repeat yeah
back to the deal so to find me another
this one's full find me another a month
later he found another one
six bed went to landlord 850
in huddersfield yeah wow brilliant so
nice big rooms
three bathrooms no on suites but i just
knew such a different house as well the
first one in sheffield
quite modern very clean white fresh feel
to it
the one in huddersfield very big old
character house
um very different feel um
so the first ones in sheffield then
huddersfield and then what's the third
one bolton
bolton seven bed in bolton oh nice yeah
so you kind of try different areas
yeah yeah or within an hour's travel
yeah that's what
all close to your house yeah yeah yeah
okay
and now they're all rented out yep how
long is the ast contract
five years go on talk to me about that
so
they're all done um
old enough five-year contracts um with
the option if the landlord's happy
they've all said all three we have a
really good relationship with the
landlords
um which is important very important
um because two out of the three have
more houses
um so we have a very good relationship
and they were all happy when they met us
to go for five years
the options they're generally given in
these deals as you know is three five
seven years
uh yeah they went for the five seemed
quite happy
um option at the end to extend and if
they're happy maybe more houses
and the tenants that have moved in are
they short stay long stay what's their
what six month asts generally right so
they're on six months and then after
that they'll they'll either renew or
they'll move
them they either relocate with work or
they stay because they love the house so
far
now you did something really interesting
as well because your partner
got a job tell me about that
so when we decided um
probably 2019 it would have been decided
to really let's accelerate this let's do
this properly
let's do it um
i was working as a retail manager and
she was working as a like an account
manager for a label
printing company so none of us neither
one of us had any experience
we'd done research read books watch
videos listen to yourself
no actual experience at all so we
thought well maybe this is
something we need to address so became a
partner
and we decided um she'd said well i'll
get a job at a
latin agency i'll get some inside info
i'll get some experience
so she did she got herself a job um a
large
lighting agency um she started
just after christmas of 2020 last year
january
and then march she was put on fella
so that was it it was just over two
months
she did there and also she and she was
pregnant we found out she was pregnant
just after christmas when she started
the job
right yeah so she wasn't going back so
big news
yeah yeah fantastic so the kind of
combination it feels like you've had the
combination of things you've had the
um the furlough and
the the opportunities yeah with the
properties but really it was your
knowledge and education yeah i think
it's tony robbins that says that
um luck is actually just preparation
and opportunity meeting yeah the
opportunity came yeah and the
opportunity was furlough
it was but loads of people have had that
opportunity but you had the opportunity
but you were prepared and then you
took the plunge and went out nailed it
and despite everybody
saying don't do it it's a bad time
it's a bad time um hmos
um you know people living together it's
covered we don't know what's going on
the world's changed um just don't do it
but the opportunity was glaring all
these student letters that were empty
yeah um you know worried landlords
um and we were just committed at that
point
so we're gonna do it regardless so your
strategy was like turning student left
that were empty
with landlords thinking oh my gosh yeah
i'm gonna have to turn it back to a
single letter and you go no no no
yeah pass it to me on a professional
letter corporate agreement and all rent
is a
guaranteed rent don't worry about it
yeah
do you plan on getting more injured yes
um
i put an offering last week actually on
when i found myself close to me
um a five bed um so i've sent an offer
to the agent
um very open to it to considering it and
so we'll see how that goes
um but yeah this year um so it's 12
months
now since i started the company um 11
months since i got the first house so
this coming year
i'm thinking service accommodation yeah
as well because that's big
massive yeah and then stop putting the
profits into building your own portfolio
exactly yeah so take all the money we're
making out of the rent to rent
the hmos the service accommodations that
um we'll get
and build a portfolio like you say and
long
long term goals is we want our own
letting agency
and um property development
because as you say you don't even need
your own money to do that
exactly so exactly well a lot of
businesses were started with no money
exactly and property is no different and
i honestly think people don't really
believe this
i think they just think it's some sort
of myth or scam or something it's not
yeah it's really not you need to go did
you ever doubt
at any point in the last five and a half
years of watching the youtubers because
you've only started having success in
the last 12 months yeah
during that four years binge watch on
youtube
did you ever doubt that this was
possible or maybe it was all a bit
i didn't doubt it was possible i just
didn't know how i was going to do it
um like i said i thought maybe it was a
longer term goal
um when i eventually got some money i
could buy a house
um you know and buy refurb refinance
that's what i was thinking until i came
across
rent to rent that was what i was aiming
for i just need to get the money to do
that
um that was the point i tried to buy the
the candle shop
yeah so that'll give me some money to do
that and then i came across rent to rent
so
it was just a defining moment i thought
this is how i'll do it
yeah um simple i don't need to buy a
house yeah you don't need much money
not to get a rent at all no the second
house
the sixth bed in huddersfield from
taking that
from the landlord um to renting it out
we've probably spent 500 pounds on that
right and it's making how much that's
that's pulling in profit and almost 1200
a month
incredible yeah so there was the first
month's rent to pay to the landlord but
the property was nearly full at that
point
yeah um it was already furnished
um again it was next student what do you
think the landlords
think when they see you making so much
money on their house
they don't mind because they are also
making their money yeah and they are
literally doing nothing
and they're in a five-year contract
anyway exactly the rent's guaranteed
they sit back
they get the money from me and they do
nothing yeah
for it so that happens yes says win win
all round
you're happy the landlord's happy the
tenants are happy you're making you're
three and a half grand a month yeah
freedom yeah quit my job i'm happy
what would you say what's your strongest
reason for for doing all this
my kids absolutely absolutely without a
doubt
um you feel
when you're a parent
very easy to feel like a failure you're
always judging yourself you're always
criticizing yourself you know even
though you're going to work and working
hard and doing all these hours
you look at what you've got to leave
your kids and there was there was
nothing
there was nothing so i knew it had to
change yeah and soon
you know because i want my kids to grow
up
and when they get to working age i want
them to have the choice
as to what they do you know um become an
entrepreneur become a business person
get into property you don't have to go
to
work an hourly paid job there's other
options and i wish i'd known that myself
15 years ago i just never considered it
never so i spent 20 years at work
miserable completely miserable
oh yeah yeah how bad did it get oh i
just
you'd sit there in the morning think of
an excuse not to go in
and you couldn't because there's so many
excuses but
it was just awful awful um
just spending 12 hours a day doing
something you don't want to do
for not much money it's just not the way
for me i just wasn't
and i know a lot of people just accept
it i couldn't i just couldn't accept it
the scary thing is though a lot of
people
go on to do that until they're in their
mid 60s
you know i mean you've now got the rest
of your life
to be able to spend time with the kids
to be able to enjoy your life because i
have to work
from a position of abundance yeah rather
than having to go in
someone's yeah with the property at the
at the beginning i said you can scale it
up as much as you want
yeah you know this is just the beginning
this is not well i'm happy now i'm going
to sit there for five years
it did seem a little bit like that at
the start of the interview
no no no no now coming in so i can relax
basically that gave me time it's given
me my time yeah so like i said
i've qualified as a clinical
hypnotherapist i can make money doing
that
i can go bigger into profit which is
definitely what we're going to do
yeah um it's scheduling it yeah sky's
the limit and you've got to believe that
and reading things like financially free
in seven days
made me believe it yeah it made me
believe it
it's funny because that's quite i got a
lot of stick over that title financial
freedom in seven days people were like
oh that's
get rich quick but it's not about
getting rich quick it's about getting
financial freedom quick yeah
which is possible and getting results
quick it absolutely is yeah
and i thought my mindset was
well if an expert can do it in seven
days maybe i can do it in seven weeks
maybe i can do it in seven months that
was my mindset
you know a different strategy you know
so i just thought what it was the belief
it was the whole
it's possible yeah you can do it yeah so
why aren't you doing it and that was the
penny that dropped in my mind
do you think you're a lot happier now
then oh infinitely
yeah yeah it i mean
furlough was one of the best things that
ever happened to us you know it was
fantastic and then
i did actually because i was still
obviously employed at that point
um we got the first house in july the
second one in august and i think it was
august i was called
back to work i've had five months off
yeah that's what i wanted to do
um but my partner becky was heavily
pregnant
she was due in october around that time
they called me back i think i went back
for a week or two because they come back
and
becky found out she was poorly she had
complications she'd found out she had a
whole and a half
that she didn't know about before had it
since birth
but being heavily pregnant that started
to cause problems she collapsed at
hormones
so it was that point i thought well i
need to be at home i can't
i can't go to work leaving
my heavily pregnant partner at home on
her own
in danger of collapsing mm-hmm um
was she was she okay she's fine yeah
she's absolutely fine baby was okay
oh fine all good good yeah um
but it was that point i thought that's
it we've now we've got enough money
coming at the moment
yeah to tide us over so i quit
and that was it so i've had now i've got
a seven and a half month old
little bouncing baby congratulations
that i've had the best time with
what's her name holly holly oh amazing
yeah so
who gets seven and a half months off
with the new baby as a dad
you get two weeks why are you still
getting paid your own money yeah
yeah yeah i've just been at home with
them it's been fantastic
um so and that was because of property
it's changed my life completely yeah
what would you say to somebody watching
this video
who's maybe been binge watching for four
or five years
and for whatever reason i'm not taking
that leap to actually just pull the
trigger and go and do it
you've just got to do it you've got to
do it do whatever you think you need to
do
to cross that last hurdle yeah if you
think you don't have enough knowledge
do what you need to do get a job at a
letting agent yeah go on a crash course
do whatever you need to do
because i said to people act like if you
didn't get a deal within the next month
act like you would die
yeah because the thing is it is a life
or death situation in a way because
you might not die but if you live the
rest of your life
doing a job that you don't enjoy you're
not living life
just getting by just existing you're
just existing and what yeah what's the
point
yeah um so and ask yourself you know
what
what are you going to leave for your
kids yeah what example are you saying
there's all these questions and if
they're powerful enough
they'll force you into action yeah and
i just went for it so now you've got
your financial freedom figure
are you still watching the youtube
videos yep
why are you still watching you've got a
new book coming out property development
yeah that's
one of the next things i'm gonna do yeah
yeah why not because that's the thing
there's always
you know financial freedom then ultimate
financial freedom then security yeah
then mission
giving back and there's you know there's
a continual growth there is
and i think it never ends no and that's
part of the failure you can't be truly
happy unless you're progressing yeah as
long as when you're in a job where
you're not progressing
it's not fulfilling so financial freedom
just to start
just to start it's just the start
replace your income give yourself more
time
figure out what you want to do and then
start building right start building
incredible
well massive respect man i'm really
impressed with what you've done and i
appreciate you coming down to my house
to share the story oh thank you
yeah it's a pleasure we were literally
sat at home during furlough last year
watching winners on a wednesday thinking
it'd be nice to be one of those guys
well there we go there we go
yeah so you've heard it here carl became
financially free
been watching youtube for many years
maybe like carl maybe you've just been
watching
my youtube videos for a little bit too
long and not been taking action
well now's the time to step out of your
comfort zone
take action and start making things
happen if you want to come
and take action and meet me personally
at the property investors crash course
there's a link in the description get
booked on let's make this happen
if you want to be inspired and hear more
stories like carl's i've done over a
hundred of these interviews
you can check out the whole playlist up
here you can book onto the property
investors crash course over here
and i look forward to seeing you real
soon in person
so that you can hit your goals to
financial freedom as well thanks for
watching
see you next time